hello and welcome to this video playing
i am prince panic good do something
different today here and see what
happens I he plays this one okay was
kind of gambling that he's not playing
this but but he he does okay it's not a
big deal I mean this is not like winning
four white or anything it's just that he
normally plays the Italian game against
a five and i'm totally sick of this so i
wanted something else try an offbeat
sicilian think we takes us more common
him i think it is ok now this this is
probably so not terrible but should be
five it looks like a good move yeah do I
want to I think can probably play this
first grabbing the pawn this is
extremely risky I think if possible at
all my trucks eh yeah so the thing is ok
I cancel maybe just robbed you one no no
he grabs it I still have compensation i
believe if he takes on c6
yeah should be not quite sure how
exactly but should be compensation so
[Music]
maybe just him
how can you believe I mean I did not
really i didn't see that this is
protected that's pretty awful okay I
mean maybe not terrible per se but you
should see that it's not particularly
difficult ok anyway um yeah 9 p-6 where
you might have a four then you don't
want to take ok may force maybe not such
a big problem i have quinta a six
set dangerous would be don't know can
something like that I don't know is that
a good night I mean one thing that
should never be forgotten is that I've
got this pretty entice push up on g7
it's pretty a good piece now that's okay
for me that night on survives not
particularly stable
maybe it's it maybe he's got some
quality here but I'm not in any trouble
yeah then it was something that I had on
the radar I was just thinking whoop the
eighth and yeah it's probably equal gate
he's got this he can damage my pawn
structure bit the bishop is still fairly
strong I wonder if I should take on the
one actually
check wasn't clear if it really makes a
big difference and I've been taking be
porn and a porn so I should get some of
those pawns I always have to watch out
also for the back rank that's a plan
that those rook the AIDS bishop age six
things but his back rank also is a
problem some
yeah wonder if you can just play like
c3m if I take a two checks me Bishop f
aid and then he makes some looked for
the King threatening Bishop age 6 I have
King g7 in such a situation where that
looks a bit awkward but still I'm
attacking me to immediately ok let's see
what he comes up with it doesn't feel
easy for me easy to me what what what
what you should do I think I take this
now just grab the paunch a young pitcher
page so yeah I have this now across my
idea so not the most aesthetic move but
I'm still attacking this one the b2 bone
maybe it just plays before him that's
possible yeah that's something that I
should have thought about a little bit
more maybe
[Music]
yeah that wasn't so great my points are
our weekend they are definitely week
look here I was going to go rook c8 now
anyway it's probably the right move the
rook c8 I know this one okay yeah in my
tea this this way you also might just
get both okay take this too can
double-check those now this be Paul is
sustained juris definitely I also
control snap he controls this stuff a
seven it's got Bishop 287 things like
that they threw gave a time come on wait
no that sank he didn't do it
okay time warning so this one can take
now no we cannot yes no wager oh that
was lucky white resides Wow yeah you
spotted it now who gave a damn prolly
jus give a damn check yeah Tim that was
just terrible yeah let's switch on the
analysis thin you as silly as a statuary
can I is why is my setup not working
fine okay anyway so if we look at this
from here I think I think roughly equal
should be correct here 98 right yeah we
have this I mean I'm active so i think
it should they should lead to something
that is equal at the end
Jim and that took it him okay I can't
play this before i saw that i did it i
felt i should be able to take it so now
each for King g7 before I have six
that's all completely logical be eight
yeah I still feel this this should be
equal the B porn is very dangerous but I
should be able to stop it of course I
have to insert rupee one this is I just
did not do that ok this is this is what
I was thinking I mean the best that she
can reach is to to promote this porn for
the bishop and this dough should should
be quite draws the comp gives equality
Joe and I look avail of course yeah here
look h8 me I'm just getting the pawn it
is not it's just not me it's not able to
get anything for it here just to two
folds down in no time on the clock yeah
pretty pretty bad game what can you do
all right okay thanks for watching